I'm so straight this is Ken and I'm
gonna drag this [ __ ] up I brought my
own because I like to shoot so all right
here we go
we're gonna put some lips on you and I
like that he comes pre tucked already I
know what we need to do and it's
sporting the new pom-pom Merkin
collection oh that's probably working
right I wish I had lashes for you that's
okay I will make some lashes out of this
old dress I'm gonna give him just a hint
of clothes he goes to the Willam ballet
school of drag is very couture
you can't do this this is the stuff that
goatee I got fired for funny that you
just put a little eye shadow and Kenan
suddenly is a woman blue marker when you
put like something blue around your eyes
that lets people know you swallow Oh
flawless is I'm kind of going Fred and
Jem and the Holograms kind of thing
difficult on metal yeah it's not a
consonant
you know fasten it with some safety pins
with some tape and your dream and you're
good to go
honey no you're gonna go to the dance
mommy's gonna get you together real
quick she'll fix your dress oh wait one
boob is bigger than the other it's a
more natural look I'm so pretty
he goes by vagina kings the jeans are
starting out you know she's the 19 year
old of direct baby drag queen and you
know she's learned all of her makeup
tips from YouTube tutorials she the
combination of Trixie Mattel and Ongina
this is my doll her name is Kaitlin
Dollaz all the drag style inspiration is
she whips her hair back and forth
alright so I was just you know very
Dolezal her stop like that's not right
my name is Lady Macbeth UM's yeah my
inspiration is gem and Ronald McDonald
I'm flipping you off right now but you
can't tell anybody have a dollar anybody
this was a really fun challenge that
with the dolls it's the same problem
with some queens their feet are real big
girl they're so booked you don't even
know they're so in demand they're like
fur
Fedora's girls I think a drag we'd
always remember some first drag mother I
think something they'll remember us
because my drag drag queen dolls stole
some of my costumes they should mop that
right out of my mother on my drag bag
that's how you get to no girl you go
through her while she's on stage I got
my pockets filled in Central Florida
you look real natural too honey Thanks
the work is soft
they said Judy's in millimeters